c'est hier soir que la chaîne info bfm
tv avait choisi de diffuser un
documentaire sur la vie de bernard tapie
un film intitulé bernard tapie les
matchs de sa vie qui revenait sur les
grands combats de cet homme d'affaires
aussi sulfureux que fascinant qui
déchaîne les passions depuis plusieurs
décennies déjà
rien ne l'arrête l'homme d'affaires se
mettent à racheter des entreprises et
dans ces années fric les années 80 il
affiche clairement la couleur
et il n'y a pas à dire malgré la maladie
qui le ronge bernard tapie n'a rien
perdu de sa verve légendaire
invité sur le plateau de bruce toussaint
juste après la diffusion de ce reportage
l'homme d'affaires de 76 ans n'a pas
hésité à dire ce qu'il pensait sans
détour de ce documentaire qu'il a
qualifié d' horreur je dois vous avouer
j'ai jamais vu une horreur pareille
furieux il a tenu à mettre les choses au
clair sans détour pour le plus grand
plaisir des téléspectateurs et des
internautes qui se sont délectés de ces
échanges mouvementés attendez-moi sperme
et je veux finir à désirs vos conneries
vous la verrez c'est dire les miels et
c'est devant à bruce toussaint
visiblement désarçonné que bernard tapie
a critiqué ce document et les choix
éditoriaux de la chaîne même quand vous
faites parler les gens gentils et les
gens qui m'aiment bien vous avez
supprimé ce qu'ils ont dit qu'ils
étaient forts qu'ils étaient importants
alors bernard tapie qui pousse un coup
de gueule contre bfm tv j'aime ou j'aime
pas
[Musique]
j'ai vu ça hier j'ai vu ça hier et juni
moi je m'appelais bernard tapie en
direct l'époque roman qui s'appelle
lambert a maintenant peut-être qu'il est
au courant mais voilà je vais l'appeler
ils sont portés à vous diriger un beau
coup je lui proposer quelque chose en
direct dans un instant à bernard tapie
juste avant vous avez vu que c'était
très chaud hier bernard tapie déjà il a
critiqué le documentaire surtout par
rapport au montage
il reproche à bfm d'avoir manipulé les
archives le concernant on va regarder ça
vous à nous dire si vous aimez ou pas
que bernard tapie se soit énervé comme
ça un exemple à un moment il ya une
phrase quand je suis dans les affaires
je veux gagner beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent
la phrase d'après qu'est coup pcc comme
les sportifs avec les médailles c'est
comme les auteurs avec les prix goncourt
cellules ont été deux mesures dans les
affaires c'est l'argent voilà ouais
c'est pas la gueule voilà alors je vais
vous montrer un deux trois passages qui
sont très très fort et vous allez voir
dès le début il n'a pas mâché ses mots
barbares capi vous raymond toit très
remonté comme moi je crois que les fans
de batam et moi je suis fan de bernard
tapie j'ai regardé hier les repasser à
23h30 l'interview donc je les regarde et
il tend à pense qu'on a plus j'aime bien
bruce toussaint qu'un jury l'a été jeudi
à bruce toussaint mois les journalistes
qui l'interviewent souvent je les trouve
un peu pas très bon il a été
extraordinaire bonhams a notamment comme
bernard tapie dit dites à vos patrons
qu'ils aillent se faire [ __ ] assure en
avoir sur de bruce toussaint qui le
laisse faire et qui a prédit par contre
ici on insulte pas alors l'adresse qu'il
a fait et quand vous les voulez voir un
peu le regard des gardes tu dis quelque
chose dont la partie centrale le
chercher contraints de mobiliser
il était bon mais telle image mettez
n'importe quoi l affaire bokassa sans
raconter la fin mais c'est une honte
monsieur quand les critiques quoi ton et
moi ce père mais je veux finir
allez-y rsf dire vos conneries et donc
vous avez laissé dire les miennes
laissez moi finir excusez moi je vous
entends si votre et un vote patron là il
n'est pas content il va se faire [ __ ]
moi j'étais pas là pour ressent ce
retard
non mais j'étais pas là pour censurer
oui alors vous n'allez pas me censurer
mois présenté en direct vous sentez
comment c'est fini vous me laissez filer
interview est donc finie on parle je
vous écris nous je me barre mais vous
m'écoutez le choix voilà alors ils
auraient s'est formée alors je suis né
juste vite fait c'est tout le monde moi
j'ai bien aimé alors il ya des périodes
de la vie d'un tapis que j'aime que
j'aime moins lui aussi le reconnaît il
dit qu'il a fait aussi des conneries ça
c'est une page de sa vie mais il a donné
aussi du bonheur aux gens et il a
entrepris et le voir comme ça avec cette
voix là moi je l'avais entendu la voix
et j'ai vu j'ai put un maire de la voie
et il dit aussi une chose extraordinaire
et dix appareils pour le cancer et 10
pour la maladie faut en parler faut le
dire ils aident les gens et qui font
parler d'eux c'est depuis cette [ __ ]
de maladie
faut arrêter de dire longue maladie il
faut surtout expliquer aux gens quand
ils rentrent dans son cas lui fera dire
que ça va être dur qui va falloir se
battre il faut pas cacher la vérité pour
toutes ces raisons moi j'ai bien aimé
l'interview j'ai trouvé ça très fort
hier alors nous on a fait nous on a fait
un truc c'est qu'on a on enquêtait voilà
vous élus bernard tapie critiqué le
montage
alors nous on a vérifié et c'est vrai
que le montage donne raison à bernard
tapie
regardez d'abord regarder l'art chiffres
diffusés par tf1 pour regarder et dans
ces années fric les années 80 il affiche
clairement la couleur
l'unité de mesure d'un système
capitaliste c'est l'argent j'entreprends
mes affaires et je l'appelais fait
entreprendre par tous que ce qui
m'entoure avec une montée féroce de
gagner
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent pour gagner
la bataille de l'argent bernard tapie
applique une méthode bien rodée
alors regardez maintenant l'arche yves
originale de ce que disait bernard tapie
et vous allez voir c'est saisissant rien
l'unité de mesure d'un système
capitaliste c'est l'argent si vous ne
l'acceptez pas ses dires à un sportif tu
oublies le chronomètre
tu vas courir dans l'absolu mais surtout
le chronomètre ça ne t'intéresse pas
pour un homme d'affaires
son unité de mesure c'est l'argent c'est
elle ou c'est lui qui va déterminer
celui qui réussit beaucoup celui qui
réussit moyennement city réussit pas du
tout or pour moi mon unité de mesure et
en argent j'entreprends mes affaires et
je l ai fait entreprendre par tous que
ce qui m'entoure avec une volonté féroce
de gagner beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent
voilà donc il n'avait pas du tout remis
en contexte voilà ce qu'avait dit
bernard tapie gilles verdez et oui quand
on fait un reportage ont choisi un angle
et moi ce que je reproche c'est d'avoir
choisi un angle bfm à charge et qui se
sont voulu se payer bernard tapie parce
que ils savaient qu'ils venaient après
voulait faire un coup c'est ça
l'hypocrisie à mon avis on le fracasse
et on voit ces réactions et ça fait le
buzz
mais sur le documentaire entre ce qu'on
a vu là entre bokassa vraiment ils ont
trop je trouve moi qu'ils ont tronqué la
réalité donc son coup de gueule est tout
à fait légitime mais géraldine non moi
je suis pas d'accord avec gilles d'abord
moi j'étais contente de ce coup de
gueule merci parce que malgré la maladie
malgré sa souffrance
malgré ses cordes vocales totalement
exténué on voit le bernard tapie qu'à
l'habitude est toujours sur un ring de
boxe après tu sens ada comme un chien
c'est ça aussi l'adn de bernard tapie
et à chaque fois ils vont en découdre
avec les journalistes et bruce toussaint
il ya beaucoup interviewé bernard tapie
et je me souviens que à europe 1 matin
il y avait dit est-ce que je peux poser
c'est est sûre il a dit ok il a posé la
question il a dit vous m'emmerdez bruce
toussaint
donc en fait c'est la particularité est
là où je suis pas du tout d'accord avec
gilles c'est que le dock et dure une
heure et après il a eu un droit de
réponse par 2 ou prou et le problème
comme ça
c'est alors qu'elle a mis l'accent sur
elle
eric naulleau moi ya beaucoup de choses
que j'aime chez bernard tapie que j'ai
retrouvé hier son côté battant
combattants mais j'ai été estomaqué par
sa réaction parce que j'ai trouvé ce
documentaire très honnête j'ai trouvé
même qu'ils auraient pu être beaucoup
moins sympathique avec lui et ça
commence quand même par une longue
séquence sur sa maladie qui est très
émouvante qui a man is non mais je
trouve le on isole deux moments alors
que le ton général
il aurait pu insister sur les périodes
noires de tapis qui en a eu c'est un
homme d'ombré et de lumière
ils ont montré l'ombre ils ont montré la
lumière moi j'ai trouvé que c'était un
bon travail journalistique et j'ai
trouvé sa réaction un peu mais alors il
ya un mois qu'il n' arrive choix des
intervenants aussi pour lui ce
documentaire manquait clairement de
témoins clés pour comprendre ce qu'il a
fait regarder vous pouvez pas vrai c'est
une entreprise en feu marchant sur les
têtes ça n'existe pas alors interrogé
plus tôt pour parler de ma carrière
des chefs d'entreprise qui ont été
confrontés à ce métier il faut donc
première qualité avoir l'instinct de pas
se tromper son devenir et la deuxième
qualité
c'est une de mes rares c'est de savoir
s'entourer des meilleurs où vous êtes
entouré de gens qui vous flatte et qui
sont pas des bons et vous perdez pas que
des points communs bernard tapie et moir
et de l'avez compris sur la deuxième et
la mairie ce que dit bernard tapie est
illustrée dans le documentaire on commet
un relais mais l'entreprise nommé est
vrai rien mais lui laisse la parole il
dit j'ai acheté pour les entreprises de
pesage ai dit que j'étais le numéro un
le numéro deux et numéro 3 de numéro 15
je suis le premier repère on le monde
comme entrepreneur c'est faux de dire
c'est un rallye où ils aménagent
jean-michel mais accord
sauf que mal malheureusement maintenant
le journaliste a presque plus
d'importance que le que l'interviewé et
là le noeud couilles la scène des choses
tout seul à mettre d'accord nombreuses
interviews qu'il a rien détourné quant à
piles et l'amérique sur la reynerie
après vous répondre il coupe non
passeront à autre chose maintenant quand
tu quand tu jettes un paquet de merde tu
laisses tout ramasser et faire l'autre
il n'y a pas moins laissé la parole
ouais vraiment le coup
on a trois des clashs de bernard tapie
avec les gens disent que c'est vrai que
c'est à chaque fois exceptionnel vous
allez nous dire après bien
valérie bénaïm ce que vous en pensez et
je vous dis j'appellerai bernard tapie
j'espère qu'il va me répondre parce que
j'ai une proposition à lui faire à
bernard tapie regarder le premier clash
de meyrals tapis regard mr tapie à une
semaine du procès donc marc fratani l'un
de vos proches pendant vos années om
affirme que vous avez notamment acheté
un arbitre il y a dix ans qu'il a acheté
lui alors ce même fratani il avait
pourtant publié un livre non mais
attendez si on passe la matinée pour
parler de ce que fratani a dit je me
lève et je vous laisse tout seul on est
d'accord et je vous répondrai pas frappe
vous serez pas la première non mais vous
avez au revoir mais non mais non vous
savez bernard tapie c'est ridicule
franchement je vais poser une question à
bernard tapie dont celle appelée parce
qu'il ya un truc commence à me casser
les couilles boisjoli quoi bein je vous
dis sur berra tapis je lui je lui dire
je veux dire mais cédera sur lui c'est
par rapport aux journalistes soient à
giuly et à bas et je vais lui proposait
d'ailleurs un truc à berne à parce que
ça commence à me saouler il ya plein de
gens aussi qui disent que bernard tapie
a vraiment à mener l'interview à la
place de bruce toussaint
non non je pense pas qu'il l'a mené
l'interview je pense que bruce toussaint
a eu l'élégance de laisser bernard tapie
répondants parce qu'effectivement il ya
eu un documentaire qui ne ménageait pas
tant que ça contrairement à ce que tu tu
penses toi eric est la moindre des
choses c'était que derrière il l'avait
en plateau donc il l'a laissé s'exprimer
et j'ai trouvé que pour faire une belle
séquence est une belle interview il faut
un bon interviewer et un bon interviewé
et on avait les deux les deux
personnalités
alors on voulait vraiment que les clashs
mythique de bernard tapie il ya celui
contre jean marie le pen style 8
décembre 1989
là c'était très très tendue regarde
parce que vous êtes un hâbleur
vous êtes un notamment vous êtes un
tartarin bleus
c'est pas parce que vous avez une grande
gueule et vous crier fort que vous
arrivez oui la seule différence c'est
que c'est pas parce que vous affirmez
fort quelque chose que ce que vous dites
est vrai parce que vous dites n'importe
quoi je vis trust yeux vous à venir et
c'est pas faux si vivement monsieur
station vous en cuir est et parce que
vous avez vos gardes du corps non on va
regarder depuis depuis toujours de vin à
table mais c'est quand même le seul en
plus reconnaître ça c'est le seul à
avoir réussi à cadrer le pen en débat
alors qu'ils voulaient réagir d'ailleurs
après le président mitterrand disait à
ses ministres mais faites comme lui les
anglais ont conseil des ministres
regarder tapie fait comme lui vous savez
pas lutter contre les pens est le seul à
mouiller le maillot
ouais ça c'est vrai alors il ya aussi
bernard tapie qui quitte le plateau d'on
n'est pas couché agacé par les questions
des chroniqueurs de laurent ruquier
regarder d'actrice humoriste est ce que
ça vous va sata intérieur qui sont
marins
pourquoi bernard s'en va sans dire
pourquoi refaire des clichés comme vous
les faites sur des affaires convainc m2
an vous arriverez jamais à vous
débarrasser de ce que vous avez voulu me
créer la verna alors vous nourrissez pas
de ça voilà
[Applaudissements]
et plus soit il faut que les gens qui
nous écoutent fasse la part entre son
passé son présent son futur on est bien
en deux minutes
moi je les ai interrogés sur le foot
après il ya des mecs qui me pose une
question territoriale eu de très beaux
moments
l'interview s'est finalement fini plutôt
cordialement et c'était aussi l'occasion
pour bernard tapie de finir par une
phase très très belle puisque ea la
faute
il nous a donné des nouvelles de son
avenir regarder un ou un mot pour
terminer je vous laisse finir je vous
laisse finir juste après il y aura alors
un gars tranche pour toute là que le
moulin face caméra vous finissez le mot
de la fin
cherchez pas à tout coup à réussir dans
la vie
mais battez vous pour réussir votre vie
c'est plus important
il a reçu notamment aussi il est revenu
sur le soutien de sa femme qui n'a
jamais faibli et même lorsqu'il était en
prison
il est revenu avec beaucoup d'émotion
sur ce passage de sa vie c'est un moment
très vraiment c'est très très fort de
linthal elle est parti en prison et je
suis allé en prison et ça a été et
durant c'est ça qui était le pire oh
[ __ ] vous n'imaginez pas donc ça a été
un enfer
on avait mis au point un petit truc avec
ma petite femme tous les tous les soirs
à 5 heures on se mettait dans une
configuration d'isolement et on est
comme si on était ensemble et ça nous a
aidés à passer le moment mais c'est
durant tous les soirs tous les soirs
vous aviez ce rituel
ouais et ce mouvement la vie le week end
quand même elle venait me voir à la
prison avec aux tripes autres donc c'est
non c'est très dur c'est très dur le
monde carcéral c'est un monde difficile
c'est la bête c'est la bête blessée il
est dans les cordes alors que l'on a
toutes envie tapis droit en train de
gueuler sur le coût d'un billet vert
aussi parce qu'on avait hier le charisme
et moi je n'ai pas changé seuls parce
que je trouve que l'interview a été
menée aux jeunes et à leurs
formidablement bien par bruce toussaint
et moi de voir tapis comme ça et que la
voix et où l'émotion je me suis dit en
fait c'est presque l'aider je ne sais
pas qui est qui qui vivent le plus
longtemps possible
je suis je me suis c'est presque les
derniers moments qui nous a fait plaisir
d'être là bien vivre long qui il a dit
malgré son cancer il a annoncé qu'il
sera d'autant à rouhia au printemps dans
vol au-dessus d'un nid coup on espère
une pièce qu'il a joué il ya 20 ans et
son médecin lui a dit tu seras sur scène
berlin pour jouer voilà c'est au
printemps une baisse assez ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle oui je vais l'appeler la
bernard iv le dos que cette interview il
ne sort pas sali a abaissé de cette
soirée sur l'ensemble je regrette c'est
plutôt il sort plutôt une note positive
est vraiment ce retour sur scène est une
grande et belle à nouvelle d'autant que
c'est lui qui termine jamais rattrapé
j'espère qu'il va me répondre
vous avez que j'ai la meilleure valeur
ça sonne déjà je pense qu'ils cherchent
ils regardent
ça va mon bernard c'est cyril hanouna
savamment vers là je voulais faire un
gros bisou jeu sorti peut dire qu on
s'est regardé hier que quand tu as
regardé hier et je vais te dire moi
j'avais un truc est bien c'est que à
chaque fois je regarde partout là j'ai
vu là tu avais quitté le plateau
d'europe 1 laier bon c'était encore un
peu chaud moi j'ai envie de te faire un
truc un jour de ce que tu sais que je
t'aime géant rituel j'ai envie de te
faire une émission où je te fais que des
kif
j'en ai marre n'émet que tu vas sur le
plateau et posent toujours des questions
pour casser les couilles
donc moi j'ai juste envie de faire un
truc c'est à dire tu vas comprendre tu
aimes le foot
bah oui alors je te faire je jeu c'est
de transférer dans le foot ce qui
pourrait se passer
alors j'essaie tout ce que tu es dans le
foot ce qui peut se passer dans des
émissions comme ça si tu es mené à la mi
temps parce que on a mis deux penaltys a
justifié un trait qui après la mi temps
tu viens et que finalement tu viennes 3
2 d'ailleurs on dit que tu as manqué
d'être un tueur ayant circulé mais parce
que ils sont conscients que tout a été
fait pour que tu calmes le match et que
malgré tout tu le gagnes
figure toi que c'est ce qu'ils arrivent
à faire avec leur sang quel accord avec
edf
ceux qui parlent en bien y les coûts
pour poser vos prêtres à l'oralité
quant à la possibilité ces salles on
était quand même de l'émission
le conseiller responsable c'est ce qu'on
a dit si wesley tu pouvais comptes
estime bien sûr c'est quand tu te feras
tu parles après en studio entre eux avec
quatre journalistes
d'ateliers et c'est pas la réponse était
oui bien sûr après sur le fait que tu me
paraissent répondait pas c'est parce que
tout le procès n'avait pas été guidée
on n'a pas le droit de parler
d'importation alors comme ce journaliste
qu'on parle il a le droit parce que
quand tu portes plainte est classée sans
suite mais si toi tu es concerné par
l'anc est tu commences à révéler des
éléments de son dossier
à ce moment là tu te loin parce que j'ai
un secret nos structures
donc c'était le pouvoir tu as donné ma
version des fêtes bat est excellent il
ya en tout cas et bah tant mieux est
juste très content des réactions ah
ouais alors si tu veux le plus beau de
tout ça c'est qu'on a appris aujourd'hui
quoi avoir en commande y en l'enquète
cumulés ça a été vu par 3 millions de
pages
c'est énorme ah oui la chaussée mais je
t'ai dis ça fait des années que je dis
que je te produire en télé tu veux pas
les écoles avec toi dans une illusion
avec toi beaucoup de simplicité
il ya beaucoup de gentillesse ça
beaucoup de démarrages quoi on sera
gueule toi que je sais ouais je sais
tout cas tu sais que je suis là pour toi
et tu sais que je t'aime mon bernard tu
le sais aussi qu'il embrasse fort
montbernard travail que j'adore c'est
qui à oui gilles verdez bah oui et adore
aussi tu vois il
on n'a jamais parlé
ces bains avec ce plaisir je sais
comment je récompense contient
l'accident qui me convient je maîtrisais
c'est parle de furiani puisque j étais
au drame il va nous en parler devant
d'ailleurs je dirais bien qu'on est là
dessus on va revenir sur bernard tapie
devant bernard je t'aime fort tu le sais
et je serai toujours là pour toi je
t'embrasse très chaud bernard bracq
modern art
révélée juste une ou deux personnes
merci c'est vraiment une bonne séquence
merci d'avoir avion va voir j'aime
j'aime pas ce que vous en pensez
les chéris j'aime 85 cents j'aime pas à
14%